[Musik]
hey lieben oder soll ich dir sagen
männer war hot geldes weil wir machen
heute was türkisches ihr habt nämlich
gesagt hier kliment macht doch mal
wieder irgendwas türkisches und das habe
ich mir zu herzen genommen und heute
gibt es die besten köpfe die ich je
gegessen habt bedürfnissen besser als es
dann wohl wir haben hier in istanbul bei
einem ganz bekannten restaurant ob das
hier ist es jetzt noch machen möchte ist
auf jeden fall mega bekanntes restaurant
dame gegessen und da habe ich mir
gedacht einen starken gegner
ja das hat genau so geschmeckt also
wirklich bei mir in der küche hat genau
so gut geschmeckt und das rezept teile
ich jetzt mit euch weil das echten
spezielles rezept ist mit zwei ganz
speziellen zutaten die ich euch hier
bereitgestellt habe wir benötigen
natürlich rinder hackfleisch hier habe
ich jetzt zufällig das fettarme ihr
könnt aber natürlich das fettreiche
hinnehmen dann habe ich an gewürzen
gemahlenen kreuzkümmel paprika flocken
die sind scharf und paprikapulver
edelsüß hier vorne habe ich doch
paniermehl für die bindung hier ist die
erste geheime zutat nämlich backpulver
dann haben wir hier geriebene zwiebeln
die zweite geheim zutat mineralwasser
mit kohlensäure ganz ganz wichtig und
natürlich salz und pfeffer die
hackfleisch nach sofort zu bereiten ist
total easy wir geben jetzt alle zutaten
ich eben gezeigt habe mit zum fleisch
und dann knete tier das mit den händen
fünf bis zehn minuten lang
[Musik]
also den tipp mit dem mineralwasser habe
ich von meiner tante aus hesel die macht
nämlich die besten kräfte weltweit und
der mir gesagt hier gehmacher
mineralwasser ein vertrau mir das noch
das ganze ein bisschen fluch liberaler
macht man ja auch manchmal ein bisschen
mineralwasser mit kohlensäure wright und
so macht ihr das eben auch bei dem
crafter und das backpulver das ist ein
kleiner geheimtipp das verändert so ein
bisschen die konsistenz also ich kann
euch das so ein bisschen schwer
erklärlich bist du einfach mal
ausprobieren das macht so ein bisschen
fluffige klar backpulver ist ja dafür da
dass etwas auf geht gleichzeitig aber
auch so ein bisschen größer also ja ich
halte man kann sich beim schreiben außen
sind die kräfte ist wirklich eine ganz
zarte leichte kost und innen sind total
weise schwierig zu erklären ist es
ausprobieren
also das ist jetzt die fertige masse ihr
könnt jetzt entweder in den kühlschrank
noch mal geben damit die gewürze noch
mal schön anziehen falls jetzt ein
bisschen mehr zeit hat man gibt einfach
für eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
wenn die keine zeit habt so wie wir weil
wir haben nämlich hunger deswegen
gesehen ich jetzt auch gerade ein
bisschen schneller dann einfach direkt
weiterverarbeiten und ich habe jetzt
hier noch einen tipp für euch ihr könnt
euch jetzt die hände ein bisschen nass
machen ich habe eine schüssel mit wasser
einfach nass machen und dann form
so oft ein mit backpapier ausgelegtes
backblech kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen
öl damit auch nichts haften bleibt
[Musik]
das gibt ihr die fertig vorbereiteten
köster in den vorgeheizten backofen ich
habe sie mir mal vor auf 210 grad ober
und unterhitze und dann müsste einfach
schauen sind die jetzt dicker oder
dünner
kleiner tipp machte lieber dünner die
hier noch ein bisschen hoch im ofen und
müssen einfach schauen wann sie durch
sind meine genau minutenzahl notierte
haben sie euch hier hast du auch schon
gemacht
sehr gut also ist nachher so das geniale
ist es habe ich euch doch gar nicht
verraten ihr könnt dieses kirche rezept
entweder im ofen zu bereiten oder in der
pfanne oder auf dem grill also ein
richtiger allrounder das heißt ihr habt
immer das perfekte rezept und speichert
es euch ab macht unbedingt nach und wenn
ihr jetzt noch ein tipp haben möchte
etwas dazu passt also türkischer reiste
passt definitiv dazu das rezept haben
wir auch noch frech abgefilmt verlege
ich euch hier in der infobox und jetzt
ist es natürlich ein bisschen nicht
trocken in dem sinne sondern aber auch
immer was zum tippen oder eine soße
dabei und da mache ich ganz gerne eine
paprika soße die geht so easy leute sind
einfach öl branche darin paprika makan
gibt paprikapulver und minze dazu gerne
getrocknete minze löscht das ganze mit
gekochtem wasser ab salzen und fertig
und das ist die fertige sauce richtig
perfekt also die passt 18 und dann habe
ich noch ein tipp für euch reist gerne
joghurt dazu das passt auch optimal eben
einfach fett am logo zum beispiel
knoblauch salz und fertig mehr braucht
es nicht und er hat ein richtig schönes
mittag oder abendessen
so meine lieben ich weiß dass jetzt alle
welt darauf seit die kräfte in der küche
nach zu machen also ganz viel freude und
nachmachen guten appetit
hinterlasst dem video auf jeden fall ein
bisschen nach oben wenn ihr bisher
hingeschaut hat und ganz ganz wichtig
falls sie noch kein abonnent meines
kanal zeit ganz schnell nachholen
dann bekommt ihr halt immer mit wenn
hier mal ein neues video online geht und
ansonsten das uns doch gerne in den
kommentaren noch miteinander schreiben
ihr wisst ja das ist ja immer so dieses
rezept ist jetzt auch durch erste
entstanden weil ihr gesagt der kiki mehr
typische rezepte und der sense und daher
schreibt mir gerne hier unten rein was
ihr noch so sehen möchtet also ich liebe
es jahr rund um den globus zu kochen und
dann würde ich mal sagen sehen wir uns
in einem nächsten rezept videos aus
stockach mal sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]